[Música]
vejo guardiões da transformação que
legal o pessoal que quer falar a
respeito disso
eu vou começar com algumas alguns
assuntos que na verdade são
desinteressantes né tem alguns assuntos
que as pessoas ficam falando não tem
interesse é pra ninguém
então vamos ver eu to trouxe aqui três
assuntos desinteressantes e não sei se
interessa eu particularmente segundo
alguns estudos então 22 mil menores são
infratores no brasil
eu fico me perguntando quem está
interessado com essa informação
é uma informação que passa na verdade
não tem preço que ela soma o nosso dia a
dia que hoje aquela soma com nós estamos
aqui não é interessante pessoas sabiam
desse número 22 mil infratores não tá
vendo é totalmente desinteressante se
fosse interessante aconteceu também né
mas trouxe justamente pra nós vimos
quanto a assuntos desinteressantes as
pessoas estão jogando
a outra coisa fisiologia do corpo tem
uma grande amizade não é isso com uma
das técnicas da risoterapia equipe fica
pensando em fisiologia do corpo com a
risoterapia em prática terá piso terapia
que tenha visitado de terapia nunca
ouviu falar fisiologia do corpo que isso
não trabalho com como empresários ou
qualquer outra atividade
o quanto é interessante esse assunto
pessoal o segundo assunto totalmente
agora vamos lá vamos pensar uma coisa
tenha um pouco melhor na cadeira de
vocês né vai ser f tranquila uma
respirada
agora tudo isso com a caneta do evento
uma caneta um lápis
quem não tiver pode ter acontecido mas o
que fez uma caneta um ato empresta um
ato coleguinha uma caneta jóia e agora
foi o seguinte todo mundo vai colocar já
à caneta
eu trouxe a minha que coloca agora a
caneta na boca a boca pode colocar rocha
caneta key carreta na boca
também já caiu na boca a boca fica com a
caneta na boca
imagina que as pessoas estão dizendo que
a fisiologia do corpo como você está
posicionado com você coloca nem a sua
postura e essa caneta na boca também
imagina você indo pra casa dirigindo o
carro no onze forno uber você com essa
caneta na boca
imagina você vinha vindo para a
universidade fazendo qualquer atividade
com a caneta na boca sabe o que vai
acontecer pessoal que tá rindo pra mim
porque estou rindo agora tira a cabeça
da boca
isso é riso terapia sabe o que vai
acontecer você no caminho para sua casa
você prepara o seu corpo para chegar em
casa para chegar no trabalho para chegar
em qualquer lugar
bem então você chegando bem nesse local
você já chega com a sua fisionomia com
um sorriso no rosto
levando alegria pra alguém
automaticamente a pessoa também para o
brasil com essa o rio você sorri porque
é contagioso tudo isso e me deu uma
grande vontade de ficar só indo de vocês
mas não erre de vocês mais indo junto
com vocês
existe uma grande diferença é a segunda
coisa desinteressante na nossa vida o
quanto a nossa postura o quanto e
técnicas realmente para estarmos bem
mudança de hábito nos faz sentirmos bem
e fazer as duas pessoas têm isso a
transformação vocês transformaram a
fisiologia de vocês por uma única caneta
vocês vão somar o sorriso que você tava
todo mundo me olhando negócio maracujá
agora já estou sorrindo maravilhosa
também mas é interessante que se fosse
interessante as pessoas praticavam mais
né
também é interessante agora já posso
começar na verdade a conversar com vocês
vocês querem saber qual é a terceira
coisa interessante
olha uma platéia interessada em assuntos
desinteressantes isso é magnífico
transformador para a vida justamente
espera uma vez que o nariz de palhaço
que é uma das menores máscaras é a que
mais revela isso totalmente diz que essa
máscara revela alguém e é justamente
isso que eu descobri
a minha não digo primeira transformação
mais uma transformação realmente para
voltar à minha essência para encarar
aquele eu que muita das vezes eu negava
ter uma oficina de clown foi colocando
ensinar isso que eu tinha que me
perguntar quem era eu que tinha que
mostrar o que eu tinha de bom e que eu
tinha de ruim dez vezes mais
você já imaginou você potencializar
aquilo que você não gosta de você
isso é para realmente entender
totalmente interessante não é
se fosse interessante de todos também
faziam oficina de clown e para entender
o que é interessante na vida pra
entender a transformação eu precisei
buscar a minha chance de buscar a minha
essência é voltar a votar na minha
própria história e voltar na história é
reconhecer a história de uma história
que eu tenho honrado onde eu venho
honrar o que os meus pais me deram a mas
meu pai não me deu isso é a mãe dele
eles não tinham que dá esperam o melhor
que podiam ter dado porque era a única
coisa que eles sabiam fazer até aquele
determinado momento
só que muita das vezes não entendemos
isso e na nossa juventude na nossa
adolescência nós vamos lhes grande
conflito dentro da nossa vida porque
nossa vida um grande conflito
nós somos totalmente 11 uma grande briga
é para o bem o mal a luz ea sombra e um
de ang os dois blocos globo pão lobo mau
mas qual o ps se realmente vai
sobreviver
valdecir que fala qual desde que haja
aqui a qual nós alimentamos mais que
muitas vezes eu alimentava o lobo mau
alimentava aqueles que realmente achar
que o outro responsável da mina
transformada transformação para o bem ou
para o mal
aconteceu uma coisa ruim a culpa é sua
aconteceu uma coisa boa aqui beleza você
me ajudou é que legal
muitas vezes eu querendo conquistar ao
entender
toda a riqueza do mundo e aí riqueza nós
estamos falando só dinheiro mas eu
entendi que era dinheiro não entendia
que é algo além
com isso tudo eu tinha sonhos ao sonho
de seu piloto de fórmula 1 tá certo no
parque municipal
então eu estava lá com aquele pouquinho
rodrigo dozzi circula aqui e com certeza
com meu pai e minha mãe vibrando
mas na opinião você o melhor é o melhor
piloto e que o carrinho todo sabe só
fica no bloco mas era o sonho sonho que
acreditei o sonho talvez perdi então
precisei voltar você honra sua história
por ter honra seu nome você honra de
onde você vem por ser uma honra as
pessoas que realmente falar
ei você veio ao mundo arambaré eu sou do
tipo sofrido coração das pessoas
desejaram que você está pensando nisso
bem coisa tudo na minha vida começou a
se mostrar que ela é feita de diversas
conexões conexão consagrado com deus a
quem acredita que ainda estou
trabalhando com vocês não estou falando
com vocês cada um pode pensar da forma
que quiser pode falar e comentar falhas
então se deus não faz sentido pra você
próprio nome
se é isso mas em pedra que você tem
razão no que é bom pra você e eu tenho
razão para contar
e assim nós temos umas conexões
maravilhosa e essa conexão com o sagrado
que dá todas as conexões da conexão com
educação e da conexão com a arte e da
conexão com social e da conexão com
inteligência emocional da conexão com o
empreendedorismo é porque com o
empreendedorismo porque eu precisei numa
determinada fase da vida entender que eu
precisava empreender prenderem que a
empresa da empresa empreendedorismo
empreenderem o mesmo na melhor empresa
para se trabalhar até mesmo no melhor
empregado que eu podia ter o mesmo
eu precisava entender isso mas como eu
vou empreender se alguém eu considero
vidro como empreender
eu reconheço sozinhas não gosto de ter
sempre que conexões com pessoas e aí os
meus sonhos e diversos tom e foram
ampliados e foram também sendo
destruídos
escrito por ken pelo amigo da onça não é
isso é claro eu tinha um amigo da onça
gente meu amigo da onça de 1 metro e 80
era negro de cabelo cristo acredita
nisso
era eu mesmo era um grande espelho na
minha frente e e aí a vontade de
conquistar as coisas de conquistar
aquele desenho animado não sei todas as
estirpes do cérebro não é isso o que
vamos fazer amanhã em conquistar o mundo
e aí tentando então conquistar um outro
choque e na verdade tentando conquistar
o mundo eu me perdi no mundo e aí vamos
lá ver o filho para pilha aa um grande
sonho do homem ter um filho que é legal
quem fazia uma mulher maravilhosa e
vamos ter filhos e ela falou ai ai ai
era uma grande dor chamarem também
curiosa essa de meteoros uma doença que
atrapalhava a ter filhos ou
impossibilitada
só que o dia 2 de junho mesmo que vem
o nosso filho o miguel vai fazer um ano
de vida
o miguel está aí há um grande sonho e
everyday meu sonho rubro maravilha
eu sonho realizado eu sou o quarto um
dos meus sonhos e aí quando eu olho
miguel quando engatinha com miguel e
quando eu brincou miguel quando vejo ele
fazer uma radioterapia também que eu
viajo muito e minha esposa quando vitor
miguel de quase um minuto é lindo aquela
gargalhada que faz isso comigo eu falo
que é um sonho mas miguel emissão não
missão é levar todo tudo de pouco miguel
miguel e legado
não eu fui olhar o hotel e parece rio
eu preciso ainda fazer muito mais porque
você o melhor que eu tenho
ele é meu sonho
mas eu tive que entender que meu filho
não era o legado eu não estava deixando
o meu filho para o mundo
eu tenho que me preocupar que mundo
estou deixando para o meu filho e pai eu
quero deixar para o meu filho e
procedência eu quero ter para o meu
filho
imagem eu quero que ele tenha e que o
filho eu quero que se torne um homem que
eu quero deixar para o mundo e ajudar a
construir essa é a minha conversa com
meu filho
olhando o meu filho eu tinha que me
perguntar a criança sonho tem orgulho do
adulto que me tornei a criança que você
foi tem orgulho do adulto que você se
tornou o sonho que você sonhava quando
criança você conquistou enquanto adulto
e aí eu sempre transformar e transformar
dói a imagem da artista pop com a mãe
esse homem de pedra bruta ele mesmo se a
teclar de ano ele mesmo se retirando
essa pedra que não deixa ele andar
aconteceu comigo eu não sei isso também
você teve algum momento da sua vida em
que você precisou realmente martelar em
você mesmo reconhecendo que você tem de
melhor e eu fui entendendo que o meu
melhor para o legado era tudo aquilo que
eu já tinha aprendido na vida e no mundo
sabe aquela coisa interessante do
palhaço onde essas coisas interessantes
do palhaço volta e aí eu tenho né uma
empresa chamada nome de um novo tipo
poder andar diversos mundos fazer
conexões com pessoas e essas conexões
que vocês estão vendo tem um centro
branco e cinzento branco é da
transparência você não tiver uma conexão
transparente com você
prefiro não teve porque lembra que eu
pensava 'que e que espera só ter
dinheiro eu trabalho com crianças com
projetos sociais e os meus meninos estão
ali fazendo circo fazendo trabalho
trabalho com as crianças surdas do
instituto da escola do sesi de oliveira
trabalho com as crianças do lar da
caridade
nós temos diversos espetáculos vontade
aqui legal a arte nem transformando a
arte que transforma é coisa que eu
acredito
só que eu falei precisa ainda de um
sonho antigo que realmente ter o meu
instituto a meus instituto não sinto
tantas pessoas
então criei o instituto posso voar
eu acredito que todos podem voar lembra
daquele jovem da da tabela no meio às
drogas ao lado dele o crime do lado dele
ele precisa escolher para onde eu vou
comentar as drogas por meio da merda ou
roupa e vamos começar as coisas boas e
eu fui vendo diversos jovens que estavam
conectados comigo indo para o mundo do
mal
há uma frase que um grande mentor meu
disse
é no veneno que você encontra um antigo
então foi no veneno que eu fui buscar o
título e comércio ou na casa menor de
maria
o projeto então posso voar com aulas de
liderança empreendedorismo para esses
jovens é liderança porque eu acredito
que todos são livres mas gastou a sua
liderança para o mal eu conheço um monte
de si outs senhores do crime pois um
monte de gente que está a fazer
marketing marketing para levar as
pessoas para a droga para levar as
pessoas para o buraco
então fazendo a diferença criei também a
escola de felicidade
a gramática da inteligência emocional é
um programa ea escola piloto onde
desenvolvo é na escola caíque porque a
escola caíque a mais na escola caíque
aquela história que ninguém quer não é
beleza é só porque do lado da escola
caíque tem um muro que divide chama
caresami que é onde os jovens infratores
dom é ali mesmo
meu sonho derrubar aquele muro e nós não
temos mais realizando um sonho que se
sonha só por isso convido vocês a sonhar
junto comigo eu sou a dimensões
espero que vocês também possam ser
guardiões dos sonhos de vocês então
história de felicidade é justamente
trabalhar com professores capacitação de
professores para inteligência sócio
emocional trabalhar com alunos ajudar
professores que até então estavam
brigados com seus alunos é com seus
professores se abraçarem voltarem para
casa e abraçar os seus pais você já
abraçou seu pai hoje que abraçou sua mãe
de saudade
quem está entendendo o que eu quero
provocar nas pessoas eu quero provocar
que elas possam se ver buscar o seu
interior para realmente levar isso pra
vida
isso sim e como eu faço isso trabalhando
7 hábitos das pessoas altamente eficazes
um livro transformador na minha vida
e aí eu fui conhecendo que tem 17
habitação adolescentes altamente eficaz
e os 7 hábitos das crianças totalmente
feliz não acompanhei tudo beleza então
vamos praticar
vamos levar esse set up para todos os
meus alunos e para a formação de
educadores também é fale isso não pra
minha vida
o primeiro é o livro tem que ser o meu
filho e por aí vai saber que legado
chegar aqui você deixa e essa minha
aluna de 12 anos num livro que nós
o livro no final do ano e se chama né
feliz idade
então todos os meus alunos desde os
cinco anos nós vamos escrever sobre o
que nós estamos recebendo e aí ela diz
assim é incrível pensar nas pessoas que
não estão sempre felizes mas podemos
fazer uma boa observação as pessoas não
nascem felizes e assim fazem algo para
serem felizes
elas podem fazer coisas que sempre
quiseram fazer dançar cantar brincar
comer encontrar amigos ou familiares e
apreciar os melhores momentos para você
que acha que as pessoas nascem feliz
não posso discutir com você porque ainda
não foi comprovado
mas na minha opinião ninguém nas feliz
jamais deixe que a sua felicidade
depende dos outros passa você sua
felicidade
esse texto foi inspirado por observações
do meu dia a dia
isadora fantasia isso é uma jovem de
criança de 12 anos falando isso pra mim
é legado é o que deixa o mundo
muito obrigado sejam guardiões dos
sonhos de vocês porque eu pretendo ser
guardiã do meu sonho não
[Aplausos]
[Música]